So my principal interest
is understanding
what goes on inside our heads.
And I'm convinced that one of
the defining features of human
intelligence is that we can
understand stories in a way
that other primates can't.
So we start with fairy
tales, and we end up
with the cases of law
school and business
school and medical school, and
all throughout our education,
we're dealing with stories.
So believing as I do that
stories are extremely
important, it's
natural, then, to try
to build systems that
understand stories
and that shed light on what
the story understanding
process is all about.
So let me demonstrate
this by showing you
a little bit of the
Genesis system at work.
I will start with just
how Genesis understands
ordinary English by
typing in some very
simple sentences
about things happening
in the physical world.
So we can say, for
example, so there's
a description of a trajectory,
and the Genesis system has
a variety of experts
that understand
that sentence in terms of
it being a trajectory that
goes along a path and ends
up in a particular place.
We can add a little
complexity by saying
the bird flew to the
top of a tree, oh,
because a cat appeared.
So now we have a
transition and a cause
to complement the movement
along our trajectory.
And of course, we
are not limited
to things that happen
in the physical world.
We can move into
an abstract world.
That's movement just like a cat
moving to the top of a tree,
but this time it's
in a political space
moving toward an abstract
destination rather
than a physical one.
But still, we see the
trajectory apparatus light up,
and now we've added the goal.
I can modify that a
little bit and say
the president asked Iraq
to move toward democracy,
and this time, we light
up the persuasion box.
And if I say forced instead,
that lights up coercion.
So now, we're going
to move on and have
a look at a very simply stated
version of Shakespeare's
play, Macbeth.
So the system is reading
away, and everything
that you see inside
of a white box
is explicitly told in the
story, but all this stuff
in the gray boxes has been
inferred by common sense rules.
For example, there's
one here that says
that Macbeth murders Duncan.
So Duncan naturally
becomes dead,
but that's not all
that we can do.
We can look for more extended
patterns in this thing
we call the elaboration graph.
For example, we can look
for the revenge pattern,
and we find it there.
Macbeth harms Macduff that means
that Macbeth angers Macduff.
That leads to Macduff killing
Macbeth, so Macduff in the end
harms Macbeth.
So when you put all that
together, it's a revenge.
Now, we can zoom back out, and
see even a more complicated
pattern there.
There's the empiric victory.
That's because Macbeth does
something that initially leads
to him being happier,
he becomes king,
but eventually, that
leads to Macbeth
being very unhappy
because he gets murdered.